supongamos que tenemos esta función esta
curva que es igual a ea la equis entre 2
más x al cubo y lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es encontrar la ecuación de
la línea tangente cuando x vale 1 o la
línea tangente que pasa por el punto 1
coma
pues si x vale 1 y sustituyó tengo a la
1 / 2 más 1 que sería entre 3 así que
juan cuál es la ecuación de la línea
tangente a esta curva por el punto 1
coma
entre 3 y bueno los invito a pausar el
vídeo ya tratar de resolverlo por
ustedes mismos pero bien como le
podríamos hacer pues para encontrar el
primero que nada la es la pendiente de
la línea tangente lo que voy a hacer es
derivar esta función
yo voy a reescribir esto para poder usar
la regla del producto y no la del
cociente porque la verdad se me hace más
fácil la del cociente siempre se me
olvida así que voy a reescribir esto y
de hecho voy a aprovechar para usar
algunos colores como que es igual a
a la x x
x 2 + x al cubo al menos 1 y bien
entonces y derivó esto tengo que de
prima sería igual a como funciona la
regla el producto pues me dice primero
toma a la equis y deriva deriva respecto
x y eso te va a dar a la x de nuevo
multiplicarlo por el segundo término tal
como está en segundo término no se
deriva x al cubo a la menos 1 y ahora
suma el primer término tal como está a
la equis
x
por la derivada de el segundo término
así que ahora de nuevo voy a derivar
ahora derivar esto es como derivar esta
función respecto a 2 + x al cubo y
después multiplicarlo por la derivada de
dos más x al cubo' respecto a x así que
cuánto va a ser eso el exponente baja
exponente baja tengo menos 1 x 2 más x
al cubo como si nada hubiera pasado pero
ahora este exponente se convierte en un
menos dos recuerden estoy derivando
respecto a todo esto respecto a 2 + x al
cubo y ahora voy a multiplicar por la
derivada de dos más x al cubo que
sencillamente es 3 x x al cuadrado ok
entonces ya que tengo todo esto voy a
tratar de evaluar la derivada en el
punto que me interesa voy a tratar de
evaluar la derivada en el punto
cuando x vale 1 ese es el punto que me
interesa y qué sucede pues cuando x vale
1 entonces obtendría
a la 1 que sería por dos más uno que
sería tres todo es a lo menos uno así
que por un tercio
más de nuevo a la 1 que sería en x y
quizás esta parte debe estar medio fea
menos 1 por dos más uno que sería 3 al
menos 2 o sea que tendría un noveno
menos un noveno por 3 por 1 es decir a
ver lo voy a escribir así todo este
cacho aquí sería incluyendo el exponente
de hecho todos más x al cubo al menos
dos cuando x vale 1 sería un noveno
luego tengo este menos así que es menos
un noveno y ahora voy a multiplicarlo
por 3 por 1 que sería 3 y tengo menos un
noveno por 3 sería menos un tercio
así que por menos un tercio a miren pasó
algo interesante déjenme otro color esto
es lo mismo que entre 3 - entre 3 que
simplemente es 0 así que parece que la
pendiente en este punto la pendiente de
la línea tangente es 0 bueno y recuerden
que llegue este valor llegue este cero
simplemente sustituyendo el valor x
igual a 1 en la derivada de esta función
y en este caso se fue simplificando
hasta algo muy bonito es decir
simplemente a cero pero suena algo
peculiar en fin bueno vamos a tratar de
con esta información escribir la
ecuación de la recta tangente yo sé que
cualquier recta la puede escribir en la
forma ordenada al origen como que es
igual a m x + b donde m es la pendiente
y b es la ordenada al origen ahora en
este caso m la pendiente es el valor de
la derivada en el punto uno coma entre 3
y
pero es lo que acabamos de encontrar por
lo tanto este término de aquí se
cancelaría y me quedaría que es igual a
b pero que ecuación o qué tipo de línea
representa esta ecuación de igual a b
pues es una línea horizontal así que qué
línea horizontal pasa por el punto uno
coma entre tres solo la línea horizontal
que esta altura entre tres sobre el eje
x y esa es precisamente la línea y es
igual a entre tres otro modo de ver esto
es simplemente sustituir aquí pues x es
igual a 1 pero esto no depende de x y
cuando x es igual a 1 que es igual a
entre 3 por lo tanto entre 3 es igual a
b de modo que ésta sería la ecuación de
la línea tangente a esa curva vamos a
tratar de visualizarlo para ver si
estamos en lo correcto
ya que tengo mi calculadora gráfica dora
muy confiable vámonos a graficar y vamos
a poner la función la función
de aquí y a la equis dividido entre dos
más equis
ahí está y yo ya había puesto los
parámetros del rango y los digamos
márgenes
previamente para ahorrar tiempo así que
vamos directamente a la gráfica vamos a
ver cómo se ve esto ahí está wow tiene
aquí una sim total parecerse luego tiene
esta jorobita es una gráfica bastante
peculiar pero vamos a tratar de entender
su comportamiento déjenme congo trace la
función me permite desplazarme a lo
largo de la gráfica aquí tengo el valor
de xy el valor de y voy a poner a x en 1
x igual a 1
ahí está entonces este punto sería el
que le corresponde a x igual a 1 la
altura de la gráfica es este número de
aquí 0.9 0 6 al etcétera etcétera que es
la expansión decimal de entre 3 pero
bueno aquí la función parece tener un
máximo local por lo tanto si parece
tener sentido que la línea tangente sea
precisamente una línea horizontal
que la pendiente de la línea tangente
sea precisamente 0 es decir la función
ahí tiene un máximo local la derivada se
anula y esta gráfica entre
particularmente el valor de la gráfica
en este punto me hace sentir bastante
cómodo con la respuesta que dimos al
problema